hello welcome to simply lying in this
session we're going to cover what
kubernetes
is and why you would want to be using it
within your DevOps team but before we
get started remember to hit the like
button if you like this video and the
subscribe button if you want to get
notified about more of these videos as
they come out and as always if you have
any comments about the content that
we're current or questions that you have
on the subject please post them in the
comments below so let's get started
we're going to break it up this
presentation into four key areas we're
going to talk about life before
kubernetes which some of you are
probably experiencing right now what is
kubernetes the benefits of kubernetes
brings to you particularly the you are
using containers in a devops environment
and then finally we're going to break
down the architecture and working
infrastructure for kubernetes so you
understand what's happening from why the
actions are happening the way that they
are so let's jump into our first section
of life before kubernetes so the way
that you have done work in the past
where you may be doing work right now is
really building out and deploying
solutions into two distinct areas one is
a traditional deployment where you're
pushing out code to physical servers in
a data center and you're managing the
operating system and the code that's
actually running on each of those
servers another environment that you may
potentially be using is deploying code
out to virtual machines so let's go
through and look at the two different
types of deployment that you may be
experiencing when you have applications
running on multiple machines you run
into the potential risk that the setup
and configuration of each of those
machines isn't going to be consistent
and your code isn't going to work
effectively and there may be issues with
uptime and errors within the
infrastructure of your entire
environment there's going to be problems
with resource allocation and you're
gonna have error issues where
applications may be running effectively
and not look not effectively and not
load balanced and effectively across the
environment the problem that you have
with this kind of infrastructure
it gets very expensive oh you can only
install one piece of software on one
service on one piece of hardware so your
hardware is being massively
underutilized this is where virtual
machines have become really popular with
a virtual machine you're able to have
better resource utilization and
scalability at much less cost and this
allows you to be able to run multiple
virtual machines on a single piece of
hardware the problem is is that VMs or
virtual machines are not perfect either
some of the challenges you run with vm's
is that the actual hardware and software
needed needed to manage the VM
environment can be expensive there are
security risks with virtual with VMs
there are security risks with VMs there
have been data breaches recorded about
solutions that run in virtualized
environments you also run into an issue
of availability and this is largely
because you can only have a finite
number of virtual machines running on a
piece of hardware and this results in
limitations and restrictions and the
types of environment you want to be
running and then finally setting up a
managing a virtualized environment is
time-consuming it can take a lot of time
and it can also get very expensive so
how about kubernetes well kubernetes is
a tool that allows you to manage
containerized deployment of solutions
and inherently kubernetes is a tool that
is really a next level maturity of
deployment so you can think of your
maturity curve as to playing code in
directly to hardware in a data center
and then deploying your solutions to
virtual machines the next evolution of
that deployment is to use containers and
kubernetes so let's kind of go through
and look at the differences between a
virtual machine and kubernetes I've got
a few here that we want to highlight and
you'll get an understanding of what the
differences are between the two so first
of all with virtual machines there is
inherently security risks and what
you'll find is we get dig through the
architecture later and presentation is a
kubernetes isn't inherently secure
and this is largely because of the
legacy code the legacy of kubernetes and
where it came from we will talk about
that in just a moment but kubernetes is
inherently secure virtual machines are
not easily portable now with that said
they they are technically portable
they're just not very easily portable
whereas with kubernetes it's working
with docker container soldiers it is
extremely portable that it means that
you can actually spin up and spin down
and manage your infrastructure exactly
the way that you want it to be managed I
scale it on the demands of the customers
as they're coming in to use the solution
from a time consuming point of view
kubernetes is much less time consuming
than with a virtual machine a few other
areas that we want to kind of highlight
from differences virtual machines use
much less isolation when building out
the encapsulated environment then
kubernetes does for instance with a
virtual machine you have to run
hypervisor on top of the OS and hardware
and then inside of the virtual machine
you also have to have the operating
system as well whereas in contrast on a
kubernetes environment because it's
leveraging docker container and/or
container like technologies it only has
to have the OS and the hardware and then
inside of each container doesn't need to
have that additional OS layer it's able
to inherit what it needs to be able to
run the application this makes the whole
solution much more flexible that allows
you to run many more containers on a
piece of hardware than versus running
virtual machines on a single piece of
hardware
so as we highlighted here VMs are not as
portable as kubernetes and kubernetes is
portable directly related to the use of
containerization and because kubernetes
is built on top of containers it is much
less time consuming because you can
actually script and automatic allocate
resource to nodes within your kubernetes
environmentalism allows the
infrastructure to run much more
effectively and much more efficiently so
this is why if we look at our evolution
of the language of time before
communities why we are running into a
social where kubernetes
had to come about because the demand for
having more highly scalable solutions
that are more efficient was just really
a natural evolution of this software
deployment model that started with
pushing our code to physical hardware
and then pushing code out to virtual
machines and then needing to have a
solution much more sophisticated
kubernetes would have come about at some
point in time I'm just really glad it
came back when it did so what is
kubernetes let's dig into the history of
kubernetes and how it came about
so in essence kubernetes is an
open-source platform that is allows you
to manage and deploy and maintain groups
of containers in the container is
something like darker and if you're
developing code you're probably already
using darker today consider kubernetes
as the tool that manages multiple docker
environments together
now we talked a lot about docker and as
a container solution with kubernetes the
reality is is that kubernetes can
actually use other container tools out
there but dr. just simply is the most
popular container out there both these
tools are open-source that's one of
they're so popular and they just allow
you to be able to have flexibility in
being able to scale up your solutions
and they were designed for the post
digital world that we live in existing
today so a little bit of background a
little bit of trivia around kubernetes
so kubernetes was originally a successor
to a project at Google and the original
project was Google bought Google Bourg
it does exactly want kubernetes and does
today with kubernetes was rewritten from
the ground up and then released as an
open source project in 2014 so that
people outside of Google could take
advantage of the power of kubernetes
containerization management tools and
today it is managed by the cloud native
computing foundation and there are many
many companies that support and manage
kubernetes so for instance if you're
signing up for Microsoft Azure AWS
Google cloud all of them will leverage
kubernetes and it's just become the
de-facto tool for managing large groups
of containers so let's kind of step
through some of the key benefits
you'd experience from kubernetes and so
we have nine key benefits the first it
is highly portable it is 100%
open-source code and this means that you
can actually go ahead and contribute to
this code project if you want to through
github the ability to scale up the
solution is incredible what's the the
history of kubernetes being part of a
Google project for managing the Google
network and infrastructure kind of
really sets the groundwork for having a
solution that is highly scalable the out
of the high scalability also comes the
need for high availability and this is
the desire to be able to have a highly
efficient and highly energized
environment but also you can really rely
on so if you're building out a
kubernetes management environment you
know that it's going to be available for
the solutions that you're maintaining
and it's really designed for deployment
so you can script out the environment
and actually have it as part of your
DevOps model so you can scale up and
meet the demands of your customer then
what you'll find is that the load
balancing is extremely efficient and it
allows you to distribute the load
efficiently across your entire network
so your network remains stable and then
also the tool allows you to manage the
orchestration of your storage so you can
have local storage such as an SSD on the
hardware that the kubernetes is meant
and maintaining or if the kubernetes
environment is pulling storage from a
public cloud such as asia or AWS you can
actually go ahead and make that
available to your entire system and you
can inherit the security that goes back
and forth between the cloud environments
and one of things you'll find consistent
with kubernetes is that it is designed
for a cloud first environment and
kubernetes as well is that it is really
a self-healing environment so if
something happens or something fails
kubernetes will detect that failure and
then either restart the process kill the
process or replace it and then because
of that you also have automated rollouts
from row backs in case you need to be
able to manage the state of the
environment and then finally
you have automatic bin packaging so you
can actually specify the compute power
that's being used from CPM ramp for each
container so let's dig into the final
area which is the actual kubernetes
architecture I'm gonna cover this at a
high level there's actually another
video that you can simply learn has
developed which digs deeper into the
kubernetes architecture and so the
kubernetes architecture is a clustered
based architecture and it's really about
two key areas you have the kubernetes
master which actually controls and all
of the activities within your entire
kubernetes infrastructure and then you
have nodes that she are running on Linux
machines outs that are controlled by the
master so this kind of go through some
of these areas so and we look at the
kubernetes master and to begin with and
we'll start with etc this is a tool that
allows for the configuration and the
information and the management of nodes
within your cluster and one of the key
features that you'll find with all of
the tools that I manage within either a
the master environment or within a node
is that they are all accessible via the
API server and what's interesting about
the API server is that it's a restful
based infrastructure which means that
you can actually secure each connection
with SSL and other security models
between sure that your entire
infrastructure and the communication
going back and forth across your
infrastructure is tightly secured
scheduled it goes ahead and edgy as
you'd expect actually manages the
schedule of activities within the actual
cluster and then you have the control
and the controller is a daemon server
that actually manages and pushes out the
instructions to all of your nodes so the
other tools really are the the
infrastructure and you can consume the
administration site of the master where
as controller is the management Yeti
pushes out all of the controls via the
API server
so let's actually dig into one of the
actual nodes themselves and there are
three key areas of the nodes one is the
doctor branch actually helps them manage
and maintain the contain
that's actually inside of the node and
then you have the Kubler which is
responsible for information goes back
and forth and it's going to do most of
the conversation with the API server on
the actual health of that node and then
you have the actual kubernetes proxy
which actually runs the services
actually inside of the node so as you
see all these infrastructures are
extremely lightweight and designed to be
very efficient and very available for
your infrastructure and so here's a
quick recap of the different tools that
are available it really breaks down into
two key areas you have your kubernetes
master and the kubernetes node the
kubernetes master has the instructions
of what's gonna happen within your
kubernetes infrastructure and then it's
gonna push out those instructure to an
indefinite number of nodes that will
allow you to be able to scale up and
scale down your solution in a dynamic
way and that provides you an overview of
Kuban Etsy's hopefully you found that
useful and informative we have a video I
am which is a deeper dive into the
kubernetes architecture there'll be a
link below in the instructions again if
you like this video hit the subscribe
button if you hit the bell that allow
you to get notified of updates when they
become available and as always if you
have any questions please post them in
the comments below we do read your
questions and we do respond to them as
quickly as we can hopefully you've got
some information out this and we're
really excited to see what you do with
kubernetes in your and fire in your
network
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here